bon jeu
oui on va
et détiennent de labo
si la boétie état
de lettres français du 16e siècle il
appartient au mouvement de l'humanisme
et il est principalement connu pour un
texte dont vous connaissez probablement
le titre qui s'intitule le discours de
la servitude volontaire un texte écrit
aux alentours de 1546 et publié une
trentaine d'années plus tard est ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que la bo ici
n'avaient pas plus de 18 ans lorsqu'il a
écrit ce texte ce qui témoigne de la
précocité de cet auteur et de sa grande
maturité intellectuelle
d'ailleurs certains commentateurs n'ont
pas hésité à définir la boétie comme un
rimbaud de la pensée savait que rimbaud
a écrit son oeuvre poétique entre 16 et
18 ans et qu'il est mort très jeune à 37
ans la boétie quant à lui est temps mort
à 32 ans il se trouve que c'est ce
discours de la servitude volontaire qui
a déclenché la célèbre amitié entre la
boétie et montaigne puisqu'après avoir
lu ce texte
montaigne voulu rencontrer son auteur et
il est vrai que montaigne et la boétie
partagés etc la voyance une subtilité et
une finesse d'analysé qui ne pouvait que
les réunir
et donc le discours de la servitude
volontaire fut la seule véritable oeuvre
écrite de la boétie
il s'agit d'un ouvrage qui a
particulièrement marqué les esprits un
ouvrage extrêmement bref qui se lit en à
peine une heure et qui constitue un
réquisitoire contre le pouvoir absolu
c'est un texte d'une grande radicalité
d'une radicalité qui n'a rien à envier
aux textes anarchistes du 19e siècle et
même si au 16e siècle
l'anarchisme à proprement parler
n'existe pas on peut voir dans le
discours de la servitude volontaire une
forme de proto anarchisme dont les
courants libertaires modernes se sont
grandement inspiré
seulement voilà la grande différence
entre la vision de la boétie et la
vision des anarchistes moderne c'est que
selon la boétie
si le peuple est dominé c'est parce
qu'il accepte d'être dominés
pour la boétie la servitude des opprimés
est une servitude consentis
en d'autres termes les opprimés sont
tout autant voire davantage responsables
de leur situation que les oppresseurs
et donc le grand contresens a surtout
pas commettre à propos de ce texte
ce serait de croire qu'il pourrait se
résumer à une dénonciation de la
tyrannie
mais en résumant le discours de la
servitude volontaire à une dénonciation
de la tyrannie on passe à côté du
message véritable de ce texte on passe à
côté de son sens profond
car la particularité de la boétie c'est
qu'ils critiquent la tyrannie non pas du
point de vue du tyran non pas du point
de vue de celui qui exerce la tyrannie
mais du point de vue de ceux qui la
subissent
du point de vue du peuple
et vous allez voir dans cet audio à quel
point cet élément a son importance
comprendre la particularité de la thèse
de la boétie il est nécessaire de partir
de la croyance collective qui circulent
notamment dans les milieux dits
contestataires à propos de la domination
politique
cette idée consiste à dire que défendre
la cause des opprimés impliquerait
automatiquement de faire porter notre
discours sur le pouvoir
défendre la cause des opprimés se serait
dénoncé les oppresseurs
et c'est ainsi que s'est constitué au
fil du temps une véritable tradition de
la critique une tradition de la critique
guidés par une stratégie de dénonciation
des puissants
dénonciation des puissants leurs
privilèges de leur mépris à l'égard des
catégories populaires
si bien qu'on a intériorisé l'idée que
le problème à l'origine de tous nos maux
c'était nos dirigeants
le paradigme contestataires c'est la
vision du monde dans laquelle on impute
aux dirigeants politiques la
responsabilité de l'asservissement des
catégories populaires
et là je suis certain que beaucoup
d'entre vous en entendant ces mots vont
se dire bah oui
c'est normal s'il ya des dominés c'est
parce qu'il ya des dominants
et si les dominer souffrent de leur
situation de domination la faute en
revient aux dominants
à qui d'autre
et bien si vous pensez ça sachez qu'il
s'agit là d'un point de désaccord
fondamental avec la thèse de la boétie
pour la boétie
les responsables de la domination ne
sont pas et dominant les responsables de
la domination
ce sont les dominer
en d'autres termes le problème de la
domination c'est nous
alors voilà une allégation qui ne fait
pas du tout plaisir à entendre et qui
fait d'autant moins que les airs
entendre que nous sommes conditionnés à
ne pas vouloir l'entendre
ne sont pas conditionnées à vouloir
entendre que la responsabilité de la
domination revient aux dominés nous
sommes au contraire conditionnée à
penser que si nous sommes dominés
c'est de la faute du dominant
et que soto attribué la responsabilité
de notre domination
c'est ajouter l'injure à l'injustice
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
discours de la servitude volontaire et
d'un texte choc un texte radical au sens
étymologique radical signifiant qui
prend les choses à la racine
et la racine c'est ce qui est enfoui
dans les profondeurs or il est enfoui
dans les profondeurs de notre esprit une
croyance indéracinable dans la
responsabilité des dirigeants de la
domination des opprimés
ce qu'accomplit la boétie dans son
discours ce n'est rien moins que le
déracinement de cette croyance originel
et donc si on veut comprendre la
démarche de la boue estime il faut
comprendre que contrairement à la
plupart des porte-parole des opprimés
labo ici ne cherche pas un objet de
complaintes
il ne cherche pas un coupable extérieur
parce que reprocher à l'oppresseur
d'être un oppresseur ça ne fait pas
avancer la cause des opprimés
et parce qu'il ne dépend pas de nous que
le pouvoir veulent nous opprimer
il dépend de nous c'est d'accepter ou
non d'être des opprimés
et là on retrouve en filigrane le
précepte des stoïciens le précepte qui
nous recommandent de nous soucier
uniquement de ce qui dépend de nous
et de ne pas nous soucier de ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous
or il ne dépend pas de nous que le
pouvoir veille nous opprimer
en revanche il dépend entièrement de
nous de nous laisser aux primaires
alors oui c'est très confortable d'avoir
un coupable à désigner ça permet de se
décharger de la responsabilité de la
situation ont subi
mais la question est est-ce que c'est
rendre service au peuple que de lui
faire croire qu'il n'a aucune influence
dans la situation qu'il subit
est-ce que c'est rendre service au
peuple que de continuer à pointer un
responsable du doigt alors même que
cette condamnation n'aura aucun effet
sur la situation objective du peuple
désigné le pouvoir comme coupables de la
servitude du peuple ce n'est ni rendre
service au peuple ni lui rendre hommage
car alors saigné aux individus leur
pouvoir d'auto détermination
c'est considérer les individus comme des
êtres sans puissance et sans volonté
et c'est là que se trouve la véritable
injure l'injure de l'infantilisation
injures de la déresponsabilisation
de la déshumanisation
il ya donc un point de rupture
absolument fondamentale entre le proto
anarchisme de la boétie et le pseudo
anarchisme démagogues et victimaire
celui qui ôte au sujet dominer toute
capacité d'autodétermination
et qui préfèrent dénoncer le bafouement
des droits qu'inciter à la prise en
charge de soi
parce que la boétie n'est pas là pour
dire aux méchants qui sont méchants il
est là pour dire aux victimes des
méchants qu'ils ne sont pas des victimes
que s'ils sont des victimes c'est parce
qu'ils le veulent bien
et qu aussi longtemps qu'ils se poseront
en victime ils resteront des victimes
ils se poseront en victime ils
repousseront le moment de s'affranchir
de leur condition de dominer
parce que dénoncer c'est bien beau mais
qu'est ce que ça apporte dans les faits
à part l'autosatisfaction de se dire
qu'on fait parti des opprimés
à part le confort de la bonne conscience
coucher en position foetale
quelles améliorations obtient ton dans
la pratique
réponse est simple aucune
et c'est là toute la quintessence du
discours de la servitude volontaire la
responsabilisation
la responsabilisation des opprimés
plutôt que la culpabilisation des
oppresseurs
parce qu'on aura beau retourner le
problème dans tous les sens aussi
longtemps qu'on attendra des oppresseurs
qu'ils cessent d'être des oppresseurs au
restera des opprimés
l'oppression n'est pas oppresseurs par
accident
n'est pas oppresseurs involontairement
il est oppresseurs parce qu'ils veulent
être et dont toutes les tentatives pour
faire prendre conscience à l'oppresseur
que ce qu'il fait est injuste n'auront
aucune conséquence sinon plus confirmé
que les opprimés ne cherche pas à se
libérer
la seule conséquence de la dénonciation
de l'oppresseur c'est la confirmation du
pouvoir de l'oppresseur
et vouloir culpabiliser l'oppresseur
d'être un oppresseur c'est lui envoyer
un message très clair
c'est lui dire qu'il a gagné
réalité selon la boétie c'est que si
nous sommes dans un état de servitude
c'est parce que nous consentons à l'être
si nous sommes esclaves c'est parce que
nous voulons être esclave
vouloir être esclave ça ne veut pas
forcément dire le vouloir consciemment
on peut vouloir quelque chose sans
admettre qu'on le veut
sans l'assumer
de fait vous trouverez assez peu de
personne pour vous dire qu'elles sont
heureuses de vivre dans la servitude
l'expression de servitude volontaire
sonne évidemment comme un oxymore
et pour bien comprendre le propos de la
boétie il est indispensable de préciser
ce qu'est la servitude volontaire et ce
qu'elle n'est pas
la notion de servitude volontaire ne
renvoie pas à la psychologie du syndrome
de stockholm
le syndrome de stockholm correspondant à
l'attachement de la victime à son
oppresseur plus précisément à la
sympathique consciente de l'otage pour
son geôlier
la servitude volontaire dont parle la
boétie ce n'est pas le désir de
servitude 2
mais à bien y songer c'est peut-être
quelque chose d'encore plus graves
la servitude volontaire c'est l'abandon
de sa liberté en échange d'un confort
psychologique
avec une volontaire s'est trouvé un
intérêt à se soumettre et il ya
plusieurs intérêts à se soumettre au
pouvoir
premier intérêt c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'intérêt pratique clabaut ici
appelle l'habitude
pour la boétie la première cause de la
servitude c'est l'habitude c'est parce
que nous sommes éduqués à l'obéissance
de la servitude est devenue pour nous
une sorte de seconde nature
autrement dit c'est la dimension
culturelle de l'être humain qui lui a
fait accepter la servitude comme une
condition normale d'existence
l'acceptation la servitude n'est pas lié
à un tempérament naturel des hommes la
boétie explique bien que le tempérament
naturel des hommes les portes à la
liberté mais parce que nous sommes des
êtres culturel parce que nous sommes des
êtres qui superpose à leur nature
originelle une seconde nature
nous acceptons que notre liberté soient
bridées dès lors que nous y sommes
habitués depuis l'enfance
et en expliquant la servitude par
l'habitude la boétie va à l'encontre de
l'hypothèse généralement avancés pour
expliquer la soumission des hommes à
l'autorité à savoir la peur
pour la boétie la peur n'est pas
l'origine de la servitude
apple serait un motif suffisant pour
obéir si les dirigeants étaient nombreux
et lourdement armés ce qui est
d'ailleurs le cas dans les dictatures
militaires dans lesquels l'obéissance
est bel et bien obtenu par la peur
mais quand le souverain et seul tandis
que le peuple est constitué de millions
d'individus
l'explication par la peur ne suffit plus
il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose
d'autre il faut qu'il y ait un moteur
interne de la servitude
il faut que la servitude soient
consentis
et l'habitude à ce pouvoir de nous faire
accepter ce que nous n'accepterions pas
naturellement l'habitude a le pouvoir
nous dit la boe cible de nous apprendre
à avaler le venin de la servitude sans
le trouver à mr
en d'autres termes c'est la capacité
d'adaptation de l'homme qui le rend
enclin à accepter sa servitude
il faut évidemment précisé que si
l'habitude et la cause de la servitude
elle en devient en aucun cas une excuse
comme il l'écrit les années ne donne
jamais le droit de mal faire c'était pas
parce que l'on a été habitué depuis
l'enfance à obéir que l'obéissance
devient une vertu
c'était ma part ce que l'on s'est
habitué à ce que notre liberté soient
bridées que l'on a raison de laisser
notre liberté être [ __ ]
le deuxième intérêt à la soumission au
pouvoir c'est celui que j'évoquais
précédemment à savoir l'intérêt
psychologique
autrement dit le confort intellectuel de
pouvoir se positionner en victime de
l'oppression et ainsi d'avoir à sa
disposition un coupable à désigner
avoir un coupable a désigné m c'est ne
plus porter le poids de la
responsabilité de notre condition
c'est avoir entre les mains un joker de
libération mental
parce qu'avoir un coupable a désigné
nous dispense d'avoir à sortir de notre
condition de victimes
et on peut alors convertir notre
passivité pratique en gratification
symbolique
puisque être victime sait se rendre
disponible à la tension et à la
compassion d'autrui
se positionner en victime c'est se
dispenser d'avoir à mettre en oeuvre des
solutions pour sortir de sa condition de
victimes
et on peut construire un barrage anti
solutions autour de soi pour se garantir
le maintien dans notre situation victime
comme on peut se plaindre de ce qu'on
subit non pas pour trouver le moyen de
ne plus le subir
mais pour le soulagement que procure le
fait de le faire savoir
pointé la culpabilité sur les
oppresseurs de notre liberté c'est
admettre que notre liberté dépend du bon
vouloir de notre presseur c'est donc
reconnaître la supériorité de notre
presseur sur nous
c'est donc validé le rapport de
domination dont on est la victime
et sur le plan psychologique le
sentiment de bonne conscience que
produit la soumission à l'oppresseur
peut conduire à vouloir que ce rapport
de domination perdure
et alors l'intérêt psychologique peut se
prolonger en un troisième intérêt à
savoir l'intérêt intellectuel voire
philosophique et qui consiste dans la
délimitation du monde en deux catégories
les gentils et les méchants
les bons et les mauvais est faible et
l'effort
or dans l'imaginaire collectif
appartenir au camp des faibles c'est
appartenir au camp des gentils
la littérature romanesque et le cinéma
sont structurées par cette ligne
médiatrice cette vision dichotomique
entre les forces du bien et les forces
du mal et vous remarquerez qu en général
la force et du côté des méchants
et les gentils doivent souvent s'unir ou
faire preuve de ruse pour triompher des
forces du mal
même si dans les faits il ya aussi des
marques les gentils gagnent à la fin
si la force est vue comme la tribu des
méchants
la force est vu comme quelque chose
qu'il faut condamner
et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui conditionne
notre conception de la domination
politique
l'effort sont les méchants justement
parce qu'ils sont les forts
et les faibles sont les gentils
justement parce qu'ils sont les faibles
faible c'est celui qu'il faut défendre
celui qu'il faut protéger c'est celui
pour lequel il faut avoir de la
compassion
mais sauf que le pouvoir n'a aucune
compassion pour les faibles
et donc à aucun moment on ne rend
service aux faibles en le maintenant
dans sa faiblesse
à aucun moment on est le faible a relevé
la tête face au fort en lui disant que
la force c'est mal
au contraire on entérine sa servitude
parce que si la domination est le
résultat d'un rapport de force entre un
fort et un faible justifier la faiblesse
c'est se faire le complice du fort et
quand on demande au pouvoir de faire
preuve de compassion à notre égard
on lui demande de ne plus être le
pouvoir
il n'ya qu'un faible pour croire qu'un
fort et sensibles à la faiblesse
la domination politique n'est pas un
rapport de compassion la domination
politique est un rapport de force
alors là certains d'entre vous diront
peut-être d'accord mais à l'époque de la
boétie on était en monarchie
or aujourd'hui nous sommes en démocratie
et en démocratie nous sommes beaucoup
plus libre qu'en monarchie
sauf que c'est mal connaître les
principes de la domination et notamment
les modalités psychologique du
consentement au pouvoir
consentement au pouvoir ce sont
l'ensemble des stratégies mises en
oeuvre par un état pour substituer à la
liberté réelle ce qui n'est que le
sentiment de la liberté
or la liberté n'est pas un sentiment
on donne un esclave un psychotrope qui
lui fait prouvé un sentiment de liberté
l'esclave n'en devient pas libre dans
les faits
la liberté ce n'est pas un sentiment
subjectif c'est une réalité objective
c'est d'ailleurs sur ce point que
portait la critique virulente de marx à
l'égard des droits de l'homme puisque
marx considérait que les droits de
l'homme n'étaient que des droits formels
et non pas des droits réels
vous pouvez avoir tous les droits du
monde si vous n'avez pas les moyens
matériels de satisfaire vos droits
vos droits n'ont aucune réalité
vous pouvez avoir le droit d'être
propriétaire de votre maison mais si
vous n'avez pas les moyens matériels
d'acheter votre maison ce droit n'est
qu'une abstraction
de la même façon la liberté n'est pas la
capacité virtuelle à pouvoir faire ce
que l'on veut la liberté c'est la
capacité réelle effective de pouvoir
réaliser sa volonté
encore faut-il que notre volonté ne soit
pas aliéné
et justement en parlant de volonté
aliéner la stratégie de consentement au
pouvoir dont par la boétie
c'est la stratégie qu utilisaient déjà
les empereurs romains et cette stratégie
vous la connaissez parce qu'on en a déjà
parlé c'est le divertissement
le divertissement ça regroupe l'ensemble
des moyens par lesquels on procure aux
individus un plaisir éphémère qui va
détourner leur attention de leur
situation objective
quand on va voir un match de foot on ne
se pose pas la question de la domination
politique
quand on est sous l'emprise d'une drogue
ou quand on fait du shopping ou quand on
regarde un film porno on se pose pas la
question de la domination politique
et la boétie montre bien que cette
stratégie a un double intérêt car en
plus de détourner l'attention du peuple
de sa servitude
elle induit ce qu'il appelle un
amollissement de la volonté
l'accoutumance aux divertissements nous
fait perdre le goût de notre liberté
et donc cette stratégie d'un mot
l'ismans de la volonté par le
divertissement montre bien que le
pouvoir ne s'exerce pas uniquement par
la force
car lorsqu il s'exerce par la force le
pouvoir devient visible
et alors à ce moment-là il ouvre la voie
à la possibilité de l'insurrection
le pouvoir ne s'exerce pas uniquement
par la force il s'exerce d'abord par la
ruse et le divertissement
c'est la ruse du pouvoir pour produire
un amollissement de la volonté et un
abrutissement de l'esprit
et ce faisant on rend les individus
consentants et donc acteurs de leur
soumission un peuple diverti est un
peuple qu'on s'entend
un peuple qui s'abandonne à ses plaisirs
est un peuple qui ne demande qu'une
seule chose
davantage de plaisir
davantage de soumission au
divertissement
ne croyez pas qu'il y ait nul l'oiseau
qui se prennent mieux à la pipe et ni
aucun poisson qui pour la friandise du
verre morts de plus tôt à l'hameçon que
tous ces peuples qui se laisse
promptement à lécher à la servitude pour
la moindre douceur qu'on leur fait
goûter ces choses merveilleuses qu'il se
laisse aller si promptement pour peu qu
on les chatouille et théâtre les jeux
les farces les spectacles les
gladiateurs les bêtes curieuses les
médailles les tableaux et autres drogues
de cette espèce était pour les peuples
anciens les a pas de la servitude
le prix de leur liberté ravi les outils
de la tyrannie ainsi les peuple abruti
trouvant beaux tous ces bastons amusé
d'un vin plaisir qui les éblouissait
s'habituer à servir aussi niaisement
mais plus mal que les petits enfants
apprennent à lire avec des images
brillantes
alors on pourrait décrire pendant des
heures la manière dont fonctionne la
mécanique du consentement au pouvoir
mais ce n'était pas ce qu'on va faire
parce qu'alors on tomberait dans
l'écueil que signale implicitement la
boétie dans son discours à savoir
l'écueil de la dénonciation
pour la boétie il ne s'agit pas de
condamner la servitude
il s'agit d'en sortir
et pour lui le seul moyen de sortir de
la servitude la seule et unique façon de
devenir des êtres libres
ces deux cesser d'obéir
alors vous allez me dire la belle
affaire c'est un peu évident oui pour
être libre il faut cesser d'obéir
oui sauf qu'il faut comprendre ce que ça
veut dire
être libre c'est cesser d'obéir mais est
ce que nous comprenons bien ce que ça
veut dire cesser d'obéir
la boétie nous comprenons mal ce que
signifie ne pas obéir
parce que nous sommes tellement
accoutumés à notre servitude que nous
imaginons que pour être plus libre que
nous le sommes nous devrions nous battre
imaginons que la liberté s'obtient par
des actes
or cesser d'obéir ce n'est pas agir
c'est au contraire cessé d'agir
désobéir ce n'est pas faire quelque
chose c'est cesser de faire quelque
chose remarquez comme notre imaginaire
et façonné par l'idée d'une liberté
conquise par la lutte
remarquez comme la liberté est associé
dans notre esprit à des images de
violence et à des scènes d'insurrection
constater à quel point les éléments de
langage utilisé par les prétendus
défenseurs de l'émancipation sont
systématiquement relié à une mythologie
du combat
lutter pour ses droits combattre les
injustices résister à l'oppression
mais ce que dit la boétie c'est que la
liberté on ne l'obtient pas par des
actes
on ne se débarrasse pas d'un fardeau en
le combattant
s'en débarrasse en le lâchant
être libre ce n'est pas vos si ferrer à
l'oreille des dirigeants s'étaient pas
les menacer de mettre le feu aux
poubelles parce que toute façon les
poubelles c'est nous qui allons les
payer
être libre c'est d obéir
être libre c'est cesser d'agir
conformément à la volonté du pouvoir
et c'est ça qui fait dire à la boétie
que dès lors qu'on cesse d'obéir au
pouvoir sans violence sans agressivité
juste cesser d'agir selon sa volonté
alors le pouvoir est nu
le pouvoir est démuni
parce que le pouvoir a besoin notre
participation active
et parce que combattre le pouvoir c'est
encore le nourrir
c'est le légitimer comme pouvoir
c'est le valider comme pouvoir
voir c'est se placer dans la situation
de l'opprimé qui réclame au pouvoir les
miettes de sa liberté
le pouvoir ne peut opprimés que des
opprimés consentants le pouvoir ne peut
avoir comme esclaves que des esclaves
volontaires
mais dès lors qu'il n'y a plus d'eau
primés
il n'y a plus d'eau presseur
et pas en faisant disparaître les
oppresseurs qu'on cesse d'être opprimé
c'est en cessant de se conduire en
opprime et on fera disparaître les
oppresseurs
c'est ce raisonnement qui conduit la
boétie à écrire cette célèbre phrase qui
résume tout soyez résolus à ne plus
servir et vous voilà libres
la théorie de l'émancipation de la
boétie tient en un raisonnement simple
un raisonnement qui annonce près de
trois siècles en avance ce que hegel
appellera la dialectique du maître et de
l'esclave
et qui consiste à mettre en lumière le
fait que l'oppresseur est davantage
dépendants de l'opprimé que l'opprimait
ne l'est de l'oppresseur
en d'autres termes le pouvoir a
davantage besoin de nous que nous
n'avons besoin de lui
c'est ce qui fait que paradoxalement le
recouvrement de notre liberté ne passe
pas par l'action révolutionnaire mais
par le retrait de l'action servile alors
bien sûr la boétie ne cache pas son
admiration pour les héros guerrier de
l'antiquité qui était prêt au sacrifice
pour défendre leur liberté
la boétie partage avec rousseau ce goût
de la vertu antique qui passe parfois
par l' usage des armes et ils seraient
contrefactuelle de dire que dans
l'histoire
la conquête de la liberté n'a jamais
emprunté la voie de la révolte ou du
combat révolutionnaire
mais le fait est que cette lecture des
rapports de domination avec d'un côté
les oppresseurs et de l'autre les
oppriment m a tendance à nous faire
oublier cette dialectique de
l'interdépendance oppresseurs au prix
même qui nous invite à des essentialiser
notre état de servitude à ne plus le
considérer comme une fatalité hérité à
la naissance
mais comme un mode d'être que l'on peut
accepter ou refuser
parce qu'une bonne citation vaut mieux
qu'une longue explication je vais vous
lire un passage du discours de la
servitude volontaire dans lequel la
boétie exprime parfaitement ce rapport
d'interdépendance de l'oppresseur et de
l'opprimé
le site
or ce tyran seul il n'est pas besoin de
le combattre ni de l'abattre il est
défait de lui même pourvu que le pays ne
consentent points à sa servitude
il ne s'agit pas de lui ôter quelque
chose mais de ne rien lui donnait pas
besoin que le pays se mettent en peine
de faire rien pour soi pourvu qu'ils ne
fassent rien contre soi
ce sont donc les peuples eux mêmes qui
se laisse ou plutôt qui se font malmener
puisqu'il en serait quitte en cessant de
servir c'est le peuple qui ça sert vie
et qui se coupent la gorge qui pouvant
choisir d'être soumis ou d'être libre
repousse la liberté et prend le joug qui
consent à son mal ou plutôt qui le
recherchent si lui coûtait quelque chose
pour recouvrer sa liberté
je ne l'en prêt serait pas même si ce
qu'il doit avoir le plus à coeur et de
rentrer dans ses droits naturels est
pour ainsi dire de bêtes redevenir homme
mais je n'attend même pas de lui une si
grande hardiesse j'admets qu'il aime
mieux je ne sais quelle assurance de
vivre misérablement qu'un espoir douteux
de vivre comme il l'entend mais quoi si
pour avoir la liberté il suffit de la
désirer s'il n'est besoin que d'un
simple vouloir se trouvera-t-il une
nation monde qui croient la payer trop
cher en l'acquérant par un simple
souhait est qu'ils regretteraient sa
volonté de recouvrer un bien qu'on
devrait racheter au prix du sang et dont
la perte rend à tout homme d'honneur la
vie amère et la mort bienfaisante
certes comme le feu d'une petite
étincelle grandit et se renforce
toujours et plus ils trouvent de bois à
brûler plus ils en dévore mais se
consume et finit par s'éteindre de
lui-même quand on cesse de l'alimenter
de même plus les tyrans pillent plus il
exige plus il urine et détruisent plus
on leur fournit plus on les sert
se fortifie d'autant deviennent de plus
en plus frais et dispos pour tout
anéantir et tout détruire
mais si on leur fournit rien si on leur
obéit pas sans les combattre sans les
frapper il reste nu et des faits et ne
sont plus rien de même que la branche
n'ayant plus de sucre ni d'aliments à sa
racine devient sèche est morte
ce que prônent la boétie c'est la
réappropriation par le peuple de la
force
non pas la force comme violence
non pas de la force comme agressivité de
la force comme résolution
de la force comme fermeté de l'âme
de la force comme capacité à simplement
dire non
vais pas crier ou à gesticuler dans tous
les sens
juste dire non
quand la boétie
introduit la notion de force dans son
discours il ne fait en réalité que
réintroduire la pièce maîtresse des
rapports de domination politique
et si cette idée dérange nos esprits
c'est parce qu'elle est un coup de
réalisme dans le visage de l'idéalisme
rappelez-vous dans l'épisode sur le
pragmatisme de william james
on avait parlé de cette tendance
naturelle à admirer l'idéal
admirez l'abstraction
réalisme c'est notre désir de nous
réfugier dans la perfection de l'idéal
est de fuir la réalité parce qu'elle ne
nous semble pas digne d'admiration
au réalisme des rapports de force nous
préférons l'élégance de la formule sur
tableau noir
sauf que la réalité n'est pas un tableau
noir
problèmes du peuple qui se plaint de sa
servitude 2
c'est son absence de réalisme c'est son
absence de pragmatisme
c'est cet idéalisme qui conduit à croire
qu'il suffirait d'informer les
dirigeants qu'ils a service le peuple
pour qu'aussitôt ils cessent de la
servir
ou qu'il faudrait théoriser un modèle
politique juste et vertueux pour
qu'aussitôt les dirigeants se mettent à
l'appliquer
mais enfin vous pouvez dessiner le plus
beau modèle politique sur un tableau
noir
tant que vous n'avez pas le pouvoir
votre modèle politique ce n'est qu'un
dessin
se demander ce que serait le système
politique idéal alors même que le
pouvoir d'imposer ce modèle est égal à
zéro
ça n'a aucun intérêt
parce que votre système politique idéal
le pouvoir s'en fiche complètement
et passer des heures à théoriser la
société idéale c'est comme passer des
heures à réécrire le dernier star wars
autre film sera peut-être le meilleur
film qui ait jamais été écrit mais il
sera jamais rien d'autre qu'un fichier
word sur votre disque dur
il ne sera jamais réalisé
la boétie nac
16 ans lorsqu'il écrit son discours de
la servitude volontaire
et pourtant peut-être parce qu'il a lu
les anciens et machiavel il ne se fait
aucune illusion sur la réalité du
pouvoir politique
car par définition
du pouvoir ces deux sous m
un accident du pouvoir la soumission
n'est pas un effet malencontreux d'une
dérive autoritaire
c'est l'essence même du pouvoir
croire que le pouvoir pourrait déroger à
ce principe croire que le pouvoir
pourrait vouloir notre liberté et notre
émancipation relève du pur fantasme
que peut éventuellement faire le pouvoir
c'est faire en sorte de diminuer la
sensation de sa pression sur notre
liberté
c'est mettre les formes
c'est en robes et le réalisme de la
servitude par le formalisme du sentiment
de liberté
et c'est amusant de voir comme nous nous
montrons parfois très méfiants à l'égard
des gens qui partagent notre condition
et en même temps très confiants à
l'égard de ceux dont le métier est de
nous asservir
ce comme l'écrit la boétie qui avant de
commettre leurs crimes les plus graves
les font toujours précédé de quelques
jolis discours sur le bien public et le
soulagement des malheureux
tirant n'est pas quelqu'un qui ignore
qu'il est un tyran
le pouvoir n'ignore pas qu'il ait le
pouvoir
il est conscient de lui même
et n'attend pas qu'on lui signifie qu'il
est le pouvoir pour renoncer à l'être
non
et de force
concept est un concept la déficience que
pour autant qu'ils aient soutenu par une
puissance d'incarnation
de la même façon que la vérité existe
indépendamment de nous mais que si nous
voulons la voir triompher
si nous voulons qu'elle devienne une
force d' influence matérielle c'est à
nous de l'incarner
c'est à nous de la faire advenir
je terminerai ça
ou en vous lisant un dernier extrait du
discours de la servitude volontaire un
extrait qui je pense résume mieux que je
n'aurais su le faire la vision de la
boétie
je cite pauvres gens misérables peuple
insensé nation opiniâtre à votre mal et
aveugle à votre bien vous voulez c'est
enlever sous vos yeux le plus beau et le
plus clair de votre revenu vous laisser
piller vauchamps volée et dépouillé vos
maisons des vieux meubles de vos
ancêtres vous vivez de telle sorte que
rien n'est plus à vous il semble que
vous regarderez y est désormais comme un
grand bonheur qu'on vous laisse à
seulement la moitié de vos biens de vos
familles de vos vies et tous ces dégâts
ses malheurs cette ruine ne vous
viennent pas des ennemis mais certes
bien de l'ennemi de celui là même que
vous avez fait ce qu'il est de celui
pour qui vous allez si courageusement à
la guerre et pour la grandeur duquel
vous ne refusez pas de vous offrir vous
même à la mort ce maître n'a pourtant
que deux yeux
demain un corps et rien de plus que dans
le dernier des habitants du nombre
infini de vauville ce qu'il a de plus ce
sont les moyens que vous lui fournissez
pour vous détruire
d'où tire-t-il tous ces yeux qui vous
épie si ce n'est de vous comment a t'il
temps demain pour vous frapper
s'il ne vous les empreintes les pieds
dont il foule vos cités ne sont ils pas
aussi les vôtres at il pouvoir sur vous
qui ne soit de vous même comment
oserait-il vous assaillir s'il n'était
d'intelligence avec vous quel mal pour
et ils vous faire si vous n'étiez les
receleurs du larron qui vous pillent les
complice du meurtrier qui vous tuent et
les traîtres de vous même
vous semez vos champs pour qu'ils aient
des vastes vous meubler remplissez vos
maisons pour fournir ses pires i
vous élever vos filles afin qu'ils
puissent assouvir sa luxure
c'est vos enfants pour qu'ils en fassent
des soldats dans le meilleur des cas
pour qui les mène à la guerre
à la boucherie
qu'ils les rentes ministre de ses
convoitises et exécuteur de ses
vengeances
vous vous usez à la peine afin qu'ils
puissent mignard des danses et des lices
et se vautrer dans ses salles plaisir
vous vous affaiblissez afin qu'il soit
plus fort et qu'il vous tiennent plus
rudement la bride plus courte
et de tant d'indignités que les bêtes
elles mêmes ne supporterait pas si elle
les sentez vous pourriez vous délivrer
si vous essayez même pas de vous
délivrer seulement de le vouloir
[Musique]